[Musique]
25000 spectateurs répartis sur tout le
week-end pour l'électrique parc château
à bouger au rythme de l'électro pour ce
week-end de rentrée après une annulation
en 2020 le festival a vu le public
répondre présent pour faire la fête
c'est génial mais en fait si mal ça fait
deux jours que je sais pas
moi moi je suis mineur 2010 9 g prendre
des points 2000 voyelles qu'ovide ça
fait du bien on sent on respire on est
tous content j'ai la voix cassée comme
il ya une copie napoléon qui vraiment
c'est génial on adore il ya plein de
monde c'est trop cool
la festivité les personnes qui sont là
la bonne ambiance déjà la musique et hop
où je suis venu pour la musique mais pas
une bonne ampleur c'est ce qui fait la
différence la liberté la liberté on est
conscient qu'on a actuellement en ville
une station qui est assez difficile et
aujourd'hui on peut vivre ça qui est
trop bien on s'est fait contrôler pas
sanitaire c'est trop bien
[Musique]
c'est
créée en 2010 l'électrique parc a repris
place sur l'île des impressionnistes en
ce premier week-end de septembre
pour cette nouvelle édition 80 artistes
se sont succédé sur les cinq scènes
c'est vraiment découverte musicale sur
blindes
plein d'horizons musicaux et puis là car
actifs oscars et a ici que c'est quoi
c'est ce que j'aime ici à alex et
essayer de vous faire découvrir des
artistes avant qu'ils soient connus
et donc ça me permet aussi de programmer
les équipes avaient choisi de doubler le
plaisir pour l'organiser sur deux jours
une formule qu'elle souhaite voir
pérenne pour les prochaines éditions